After Game of Thrones Jason Momoa felt
pigeonholed not for his incredible
physique and rakish good looks but for
his grasp of the English language since
Game of Thrones aired its first season
back in 2011 Jason Momoa has gathered a
massive following due to his performance
as called rogo a warlord of the Dothraki
Warriors Game of Thrones itself became a
Monumental hit as well arguably one of
the biggest shows to ever air as for
Momoa Drogo wasn't his first significant
role as he also played the lead in
2011's Conan the Barbarian along with
his first ever credited role on the
original Baywatch if you haven't seen
Momoa in these two early roles or even
in Game of Thrones you have likely seen
him Star as Aquaman in the DC Universe
movies or his Apple TV plus series C he
also played the famed character of
Duncan Idaho in the 2021 Dune film
adaptation suffice it to say the actor
has amassed a great resume given how
popular the stars become in both the
film and TV space you might be surprised
to know that one of these roles nearly
stunted his rise to the top and no it
isn't Baywatch
I'm me one thing one piece one person
all together
as Jason Momoa spoke about in an
interview with Jimmy Fallon on The
Tonight Show the actor's breakout role
is called rogo in Game of Thrones
actually hampered his career rather than
boosting it apparently his performance
as Drogo particularly is adept handling
of the fictional Dothraki language was
so convincing that many people in the
entertainment industry thought that
Momoa couldn't speak English that well
which pigeonholed him as Mamoa put it
Momoa went on to recall an encounter
with actor Fred Armisen they met because
momoa's stepdaughter Zoe Kravitz acted
in Portlandia Momoa said that armeson
professed how much he was a fan of his
performance in Game of Thrones but that
he hadn't known that the actor spoke
English it was heartbreaking I was like
that's why I'm not getting any jobs
fortunately for Momoa Zack Snyder was an
even bigger fan of his than armeson and
the director soon called Mamoa to come
in to audition for a vaguely described
DC movie supposedly for the role of
Batman Weeks Later Snyder offered Mamoa
the role of Aquaman instead and the rest
is history thankfully it's pretty clear
to mainstream Hollywood now that Mamoa
is a native English speaker nonetheless
the actor's ability to speak other
languages especially the fictional kind
is clearly better than most knowing that
Jason Momoa struggled to break out of
his Typecast image for years after
amassing popularity in Game of Thrones
is heartbreaking enough but the portrait
the actor paints of his life during this
time is even darker in an interview with
in style Mamoa revealed that during the
period between Game of Thrones and his
casting as Aquaman he struggled to
support his family including his two
newborn children and his then wife Lisa
Bonet Momoa told the outlet I mean we
were starving after Game of Thrones I
couldn't get work it's very challenging
when you have babies and you're
completely in debt even while he was
still filming for Game of Thrones Momoa
was already contending with financial
troubles in a 2019 Instagram post the
actor recalled a story from one Mega
popular series had paused production in
Ireland and he couldn't afford a flight
home not one to wallow in a bad
situation however Momoa sees the
opportunity to go on a cross-country
road trip with his friend film producer
Brian Andrew Mendoza Momoa wrote in the
caption who rented a panel van AKA
U-Haul in Belfast and drove around
beautiful amazing Ireland searching for
the greatest pint of Guinness so many
wonderful people and stories I treasure
those times while Momoa may have
struggled during this early career
period it's nice to know that the actor
still looks back on his time filming
Game of Thrones with some fondness
foreign